[Music]
aging it's the price we pay for a living
but it might not always be this way
I think that in 50 years we'll be able
to take a 20 year old and give them a
treatment where they'll be Peter Pan
they'll be forever young increasingly
science is revealing how we can slow our
biological clocks the rate of Aging is
malleable and these tantalizing glimpses
of an ageless future are attracting huge
money big investors are zeroing in on
age reversal research but does the
science live up to the hype can we
really slow down aging or even stop it
altogether when I started the field it
was like well let's let's see we moved
from Hope to realizing the promise
[Music]
if we can slow aging enough
so that we don't have diseases of Aging
then we will be happy
but there will be a side effect we might
live longer
I want you to walk back to me calling
off every other letter of the alphabet
starting with a
[Music]
C
she might not look it but gitty is 98
years old she's a participant in the
longevity jeans project at the Albert
Einstein College of Medicine in New York
my brother died in his mid-80s my sister
is now 103 I have a younger sister who
is 90. my father died
five days short of 95. my mother died at
85 or 86.
[Music]
not only longer they live healthier for
the past 25 years near barzalai has
studied the long-lived in a bid to
unlock the mystery of Aging when I
started studying the centenarian the
question is do they just live longer or
do they also live healthier and the
answer is yes they're healthy we have
discovered several genes in our
centenarians if we can imitate them if
we can understand what happens to them
we can create it as a drug or or some
other intervention that we could use
nears just one of a growing number of
scientists chasing a future where aging
is no longer inevitable
but what is aging the longer you live
the greater the impact of molecular and
cellular damage in your body bringing
you closer to death as to why we age one
explanation is the Disposable Soma
Theory
there's an evolutionary trade-off
between repair and reproduction
it's not obvious why an animal should
become more damage as it gets older and
The evolutionary explanation is a thing
called disposable Soma Theory and for
that you have to understand that the
purpose of an organism is to reproduce
and since he's always at risk of getting
killed by the outside world it makes
sense to get your reproducing done as
fast as possible so organisms tend to
reproduce when they're young
evolutionary pressure to keep them in
all working order as they get older
diminishes
an adult human's risk of death doubles
roughly every eight years at 30 years of
age your odds of dying in the next year
are less than 0.1 percent at 60 years of
age that risk is one percent
by the time you turn 90 it's over 15
percent
but this isn't true for all animals
aldabra giant tortoises for example can
live to well over 100. and as adults the
risk of death remains roughly constant
at just over two percent per year
biologically speaking they hardly age at
all
so if aging isn't fixed maybe it can be
changed
in the 1930s a paper by Clyde McKay a
scientist at Cornell University in New
York state proved just that with one
simple modification he revealed a way to
make animals stay healthy for longer
and even prolong their lives
McKay found that if he restricted the
diet of rats to near starving levels he
could increase their lifespan by up to
33 percent that was the first time that
we discovered that agent could be slowed
down and it's true well pretty well
every animal has been tested on
from yeast to dogs
it sounds counter-intuitive but in
evolutionary terms it fits with the
Disposable Soma theory if you are
selling then reproduction is possibly
not top of your list of things to do you
want to survive and so a mechanism that
will prolong life then to allow the
animal to arrive at a point where it
could reproduce successfully make sense
Evolution will wish to preserve the
animal for a better time but it does
preserve Health as well it's not that
you have a horrible old age you have a
healthy old age but keeping yourself
hungry for a longer healthier life is
far from ideal
the trick would be to fool the body into
thinking it's starving when it's not
and the key to that may lurk in our DNA
[Music]
in the 1990s Cynthia Kenyon made
headlines when her groundbreaking work
with round worms showed for the first
time that genes can play a part in aging
amazingly we found that changing a gene
called daf2 could in one Fell Swoop
double the lifespan of the animal and
cause it to age much more slowly than
normal so that it stayed Young
much longer than normal
since then scientists have tweaked
various genes in roundworms resulting in
mutants that can live to over five
months old ten times longer than those
without the genetic changes we now know
from work from our lab and from other
labs that the reason that this Gene
change slows down
aging is because the genes that we
changed are involved in a kind of
programmed system of resiliency
they make the animals less sensitive to
pathogens they improve the ability of
the animal to repair its DNA
all sorts of things it's pretty amazing
they're the same changes responsible for
increasing lifespan in near starving
animals only this time the animal can
eat as much as it wants because its
genes have been tricked into thinking
it's starving
and humans have the genes they're right
there in us but we don't yet know
whether they affect our lifespan or not
researchers have discovered other genes
that affect Aging in humans but changing
genes in people is irreversible a more
practical way to slow aging would be to
change not genes themselves but how
they're read modifying something called
the epigenome
epigenetics literally means on top of
genes so you can think of it as a layer
of information that are added to the DNA
the epigenome Tells genes when to turn
on and off there is a very promising
therapeutic Avenue that is being
investigated now called epigenetic
reprogramming tweaking the epigenome of
mice has already shown it's possible to
turn back a cell's biological clock in
particular manipulating four proteins
known as yamanaka factors and if you
express those yamanaka factors in Old
cells they change the epigenome and push
the cell back in time
epigenetic treatments are showing so
much potential that research money is
flooding in startups betting they can
modify the epigenome to slow down aging
or popping up all over Silicon Valley
and elsewhere
the claims might sound outlandish but
the science is real
epigenetics
are epigenetic patterns are laid down by
enzymes which by Nature catalyze mostly
reversible reactions and therefore if we
can Target the correct enzymes to change
those patterns and convert them back to
the youthful pattern
then it means that epigenetics is a
druggable field of research in terms of
anti-aging
while a drug that can fight aging at the
DNA level remains closer to Theory than
practical application other methods of
turning back the biological clock
already exist for the past few years
I've been endeavoring to build the
world's best anti-aging protocol
some attempts to slow aging are raising
eyebrows
take Brian Johnson the man who Zeal for
a long life is viewed as obsessive by
many these are all the supplements I
take in his quest to remain Forever
Young he's pushed boundaries even using
his own son's blood we'll lead her out
we'll lead her in for me as Macabre as
it sounds it seems to work in animals
it's known as parabiosis
it's almost like another vampire story
parabolous is when you take two animals
of the same species and Link their blood
circulations together if you do it with
animals of significantly different ages
so one's quite young and one's quite old
the older animal lives longer than you
would expect although how much of this
is down to special qualities in the
younger blood is open to debate there
probably are some factors of the
crossing over from the young to the old
but it looks as though a lot of the
effect is coming simply from the
dilution of the bad factors of the old
animal
and blood isn't the only gift the young
can donate to provide the old with
youthful vigor if you transplant easy
from a young animal to an old animal
that will extend its lifespan not much
is known yet about why this works but
the microbiome the bacteria in the gut
changes with age presumably it's
adapting to the the host we know the
composition of the microbium changes as
the animal gets old and it becomes more
specific so this might be a way that you
can get its longevity through the Dutch
it might take blood and guts to stay
this young but a range of different
drugs are also showing promise at
slowing down aging and some of them have
been on pharmacist shelves for years
a class of drugs that includes the
satinum used to treat leukemia has been
found to extend life in Animals by
attacking a major contributor to aging
there's a certain kind of cell called a
senescence cell it could have been any
cell in your body but when it becomes
senescent it stops dividing no longer
proliferates and it becomes highly
inflammatory it's a little Center of
inflammation right there in your body
and that's a problem because
inflammation is linked to a variety of
age-related diseases
in animals where they've cleared
senescent cells it's really remarkable
the animals don't live that much longer
but they're much healthier
currently there are nearly 20 clinical
trials globally for therapies that clear
senescent cells
but this isn't the only class of drug
that shows promise in slowing aging
this one is metformin it's been also
taken off label for longevity purposes
metformin is a common drug to treat
diabetes but also the people who are
using that are protected against variety
of age-related diseases
metformin mimics dietary restriction by
lessening the amount of sugar the body
produces and absorbs the way it works
inside a cell isn't completely
understood but it reduces inflammation
and helps break down accumulated rubbish
in studies diabetics taking metformin
have lived longer and healthier than
people not on the drug whether they were
diabetic or Not
Another drug that seems to slow aging is
rapamycin already approved for use with
organ transplants
rapamycin is an immunosuppressant it
changes the way that nutrients are are
sensed and changes to the way that
they're metabolized in ways which are
useful to extending life rapamycin
boosts the way cells clear up junk that
builds up inside them with age this
means they can function better like a
younger version of themselves
whether they're drugs that already exist
or new ones that change our epigenome
anti-aging treatments are coming and the
need for them has never been greater
we all know that we have a demographic
shift in which fewer young people are
supporting more old people
so it's really really important that our
older people
stay vibrant and Youthful and productive
it's also something we all want for
ourselves and for our family and people
we love and for everybody a future where
we grow old without aging would benefit
billions and give the world an economic
Boon too it's not a billion dollar
question it's trillions the last two
years of medical expense of centenarians
is third of those who die at seven
if people lived longer with a sharper
decline in old age it would reduce
medical expenses resulting from
age-related diseases
although it's impossible to put a price
on extra years of healthy life
one day hopefully more of us will be as
independent into old age as gitty
as I look back
Whoever thought of 98
when I was in my 60s I never thought of
that but today 50 is like being a baby I
want to beat my sister right now my
sister is 103.
I want to be able to live that long 120
thank you for watching to read more
about the science of Life Extension
click the link and don't forget to
subscribe